the K Santos
not on your lights
hello girls
it's the last body shot competition so
we are going to salt a you up
I've had it with love I don't believe
it's relevant to the 21st century
lesbian
you're not wearing that I just came from
work I came from Toledo I don't dress
like it I'm not here to Pedal my Wares
in town I am too that was my plan where
are you going Tallahassee Florida I've
been unhappy that's why we take this
trip together honey babe we get our act
together together
girlies Drive Away Pennsylvania's most
trusted name and car delivery here don't
call me curly
and your name curly my name is Curly we
just met it's too familiar
we're here for the car wait a minute you
call with a drop off in Tallahassee and
then these broads come in and say
they're ready to go to Tallahassee
they drive the car instead of you is
that bad bad if they find the goods
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's locked
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand that you're unhappy sir we
will find and deliver the package we
just want your friends
you cannot relate to the public which in
the service profession is a big handicap
did the two creeps find you they know we
have their stuff maybe we sell it back
shake them down all right they like
wanted or something oh no they're not in
trouble at all I'm gonna help you break
a big murder case that is about the
dumbest thing I've ever heard and I'm a
cop
who are you Democrats
wow you've had a full day
foreign